hexago presents Miss Ethel Merman
[Music]
in our modern capitalistic world with
Center billionaires and multi-trillion
dollar Mega cap companies hostile
takeovers are a dime a dozen Elon Musk
just had one last year with Twitter more
times than not though such hostile
takeovers don't actually benefit the
company being taken over all that much
sometimes the acquirer will dissect and
to keep the desirable parts of the
company and it viciously shut down or
sell off the other parts as was the case
with the Google and Motorola Google took
over much of Motorola 17 000 patents and
sold the remaining corpse to Lenovo
other times acquirers will bury the
original company and attain the products
that they run with as was the case with
Oracle and Sun Microsystems Java in the
80s and 90s song was an I.T giant but
today the brand is virtually
non-existent because of Oracle to make
things worse Oracle annihilated the
reputation of java by trying to to
Google for their use of it if none of
this has transpired after an acquisition
it may just be a successful one but even
then that's only in the eyes of the
acquirer and shareholders oftentimes the
original team who founded the company is
completely kicked out and robbed as was
the case with both Instagram and
WhatsApp things have gotten so bad
between whatsapp's Founders and
Zuckerberg that whatsapp's Founders are
literally advocating for people to
delete Facebook the original Founders
aren't the only victims in such
takeovers either while a big Mighty
Monopoly might be a dream for investors
the same cannot be said about consumers
so in almost every case hostile
takeovers end up hurting the original
company the original product the
founders and or the public but this is
simply the reality of our modern
capitalistic Society however there are
some rare cases in which the Brash
acquirers get a taste of their own
medicine such was the case with the
Texaco and the Getty oil which was at
the time it the largest Takeover in
history this made sense as Texaco was
the sixth largest company in the world
and they were hoping that this
acquisition isn't just what they needed
to overtake Exxon and to claim the crown
as the world's largest company but
little did they know that this hostile
takeover would not just be a nightmare
but straight up be fatal just three
years later Texaco would file for
bankruptcy and the company has been
completely forgotten about since so
here's how one hostile takeover
destroyed the entire Empire of Texaco
foreign
taking a look back the story of texaco's
demise can be traced back to the feud of
a completely unrelated family the Getty
family the Getty family was the owners
of a Getty oil which was at one point
one of the largest companies in the
world in fact it's a Visionary founder
John Paul Getty senior was regularly
listed as the richest man in the world
for example 1957 Fortune listed him as
the richest man alive and in 1966
Guinness listed him as the world's
richest pirate citizen let's just say
this guy was a billionaire back in their
50s and 60s so he was really rich but he
didn't let this wall to get to his head
he understood how volatile his fortune
was and that much of his wealth was just
on paper Jon was a shrewd businessman
who was extremely Frugal and obsessed
over every deal in fact he learned
Arabic so that he could personally
negotiate deals in the Middle East and
not get screwed over by translators he
would also wash his clothes by hand
because he didn't want to pay anyone
else to do it unfortunately though this
mentality did not rub off on his family
whatsoever and this would become a
painfully evident throughout the 1970s
Getty oil would take a substantial hit
from the 1973 oil crisis though this was
nothing that Jon couldn't recover from
something that he actually couldn't
recover from though was that and that
this was his Fate In 1976 at the age of
83. Getty oil was mostly family owned so
you would think that they would all join
forces and try to protect this family
Empire but the reality was that they
were all way too busy arguing over who
would get control of the fortune this
was the case with everyone except for
Jon's youngest son Gordon Getty Gordon
didn't really care about the family
business this isn't to say that he
wasn't a grateful for his wealth but
simply that he wasn't looking to run the
company or take it to the Moon instead
it he just wanted to write music and
appreciate Opera and funnily enough
that's exactly what he's been doing this
day so you could say that money and the
power hadn't really corrupted him yet
the rest of Gordon's family was
astonished by his nonchalance to the
whole situation so they figured that he
would be the most level-headed person to
have control of the company this was a
terrible idea the reason Gordon was so
nonchalant about the whole situation was
because it didn't concern him Gordon's
ideal scenario was selling off the
company getting a massive payout and
moving on with his life and this is
eventually what he would do but we'll
get to that later
to hand over substantial control over
the company to such a guy was simply
brain dead Behavior the family also
handed over substantial control to a
trusted family lawyer named C Lansing
Hayes Jr now it's not clear how good of
a businessman this guy was but at least
he wasn't hopelessly incompetent this
Arrangement would take the company
through the next six years but in 1982 C
Lansing would also pass away which meant
that his control would roll over to
Gordon Gordon now had a 40 stake in
Getty oil but let's just say he was
still as clueless as ever
foreign
had such a large stake in the company he
felt that he was obliged to do something
so he started with trying to address the
Rock Bottom stock price you see it the
oil that the company owned itself should
have given the company evaluation of 100
per share but the company was somehow
trading at just 50 dollars per share so
Gordon decided that it would be a
brilliant idea to bring in some external
help but he would walk straight into the
jaws of a shark T Boone Pickens this guy
was one of the most infamous corporate
Raiders of all time and back in the
1980s this was the number one guy you
wanted to avoid as a struggling company
yet Gordon would go straight to this guy
and divulge a bunch of company secrets
you know how they say that if you have a
good experience with a car salesman you
probably got scammed well this sentiment
couldn't not be a tour with Gordon and T
Boone Pickens Gordon felt that Pickens
gave him really good advice and that it
would would be a good idea to set up a
meeting with the chairman of Getty
Sydney Peterson Peterson actually went
into the meeting with an open mind but
he quickly realized that Gordon had
already spilled the beans and he could
see exactly what Pickens was trying to
do so he would instantly Force Pickens
to sign an agreement that he wouldn't
attempt a hostile takeover Peterson
probably left the meeting with the sigh
of relief that he was able to cover for
Gordon's blunder and stay one step ahead
of Pickens but it didn't take long for
Gordon to start talking with yet another
shark the Bass Brothers fearful that
Gordon was gonna Leak Company secrets to
all of Wall Street Peterson would bring
in excellent advisors of his own in 1983
Goldman Sachs Goldman didn't know about
the distrust between the board and
Gordon so they would make a
recommendation purely based on the
financials of a company Goldman
suggested that Getty buy back 500
million dollars worth of stock given
that their stock was trading for half
the value of their oil this was great
advice if they were able to complete
this bypass back and follow it up with a
strong corporate turnaround it would
simply be even richer but there was one
fatal flaw with this plan if the company
followed through with this repurchase
plan Gordon would end up with over a 50
stake meaning that he can do whatever he
wanted it without the board this would
be suicide for the company and that this
was simply confirmed by Gordon's
incoherent statement that followed he
said a quote what I really want is to
find the optimum way to optimize value
so they would go ahead and reject the
idea of a stock buyback but this simply
increased The Strife between the board
and the Gordon Gordon started to feel
that the next step for the company
wasn't to get external help but to get
rid of the board and this led to all-out
war
all Gordon had to do was figure out how
to increase his stake by a mere 10 and
it didn't take him that long to find the
perfect Target The Getty Museum The
Getty Museum owned a 12 of the company
and was led by a man named Harold
Williams
Gordon could get Williams on his side it
well then he could kick out the board
and sell the company and move on to win
over William's support Gordon offered to
buy out the shirt of the museum at a
very favorable price but Williams didn't
want any part of this nonsense but he
wouldn't change his mind after a new
development you see it wasn't just
Gordon that was trying to kick out the
board the board was trying to reduce
Gordon's influence as well so they had
recruited Gordon's 15 year old nephew to
sue his Uncle Gordon it into
implementing a co-trust e but this move
would also push Williams over the edge
he couldn't believe that the board was
leveraging children to push out Gordon
so he would agree to help Gordon sell
the company to accomplish this he would
bring in the CEO of Pennzoil chulitki
Pennzoil wasn't big enough to buy out
the entirety of Getty but they could
help Gordon get rid of the board the
plan was that litke would buy 20 of
Getty at 100 per share which would give
him a seat on the board from there he
could buy at a museum which would allow
him and Gordon to take over the company
this put the board in a super sticky
situation they couldn't outright refuse
or accept the offer this offer was
substantially higher than the stock was
trading for so if they rejected the
offer they would open themselves up to
shareholder lawsuits at the same time
though Goldman valued the company at 120
per share so if they accepted the offer
they would still open themselves up to
shareholder lawsuits the board countered
that they would do the deal for 120
dollars but litke was only willing to go
up to 112.50 at this point the board
could have put up more resistance but
that wouldn't have accomplished much if
they turned on lidkey Gordon would
simply become even more aggressive and
to bring in someone else so with that
all parties would agree to the deal in
principle and it seemed like this is how
this multi-year Family Feud would
finally end but then out of nowhere
Texas go would step in they said forget
120 we'll buy everything for 125. we'll
buy the public share Gordon shared the
museum and share everything this was a
win-win-win-win scenario the board was
not only able to sell the company for
slightly more than fair value but they
can ensure that Gordon wouldn't get
control of the company either as for
Gordon well he didn't want the company
in the first place what he wanted was
out so he was happy to take the money
and to focus on music meanwhile the
museum was able to get out of this drama
without having decided with the board or
Gordon and as for Texaco well now they
had a chance at overtaking Exon and
becoming the world's largest company
given that all parties were ecstatic the
deal would go through it in no time but
there was one person who wasn't happy at
all huliki
foreign
completed the deal with Texaco they had
already agreed to do the deal with
Pennzoil in principle Texaco was aware
of this but they assumed that Pennzoil
would just let it go in the end they had
put up a good fight and they were close
but no cigar Texaco had to come out on
top and it was time for Pennzoil to
accept their loss and move on but
Pennzoil had different plans they had
already struck a deal with Getty and it
was not only distasteful for Texaco to
step in it but a breach of contract and
Pennzoil was gonna get revenge through
legal means this was a nightmare for
Texaco they had to just bet the farm on
Getty they spent 9.9 billion dollars on
the acquisition which was again at the
largest in history this was by no means
a small amount for even Texaco
themselves at the time they were
profiting about 1.2 billion dollars per
year so they had basically about 80
years worth of profit on getting and who
knows how much debt and leverage they
had to use to complete this acquisition
so Texaco had no doubt it made a risky
bet with Getty but they felt that if
they could just turn around the company
they would be rewarded insanely this
lawsuit however through a wrench in all
of their plans the last thing they
wanted to do was fight another oil giant
or Worse payout of billions of dollars
to them Pennzoil nonchalantly wanted a
full 10.53 billion dollars and a given
that they did have that deal in
principle it was easy for the jury to
decide with Pennzoil for Texaco this was
a death sentence at least with the Getty
they were getting an income producing
entity with assets employees and
reputation with the lawsuit the money
was just going straight to pennzoil's
bottom line Texaco would of course
appeal and the case would go to the
Supreme Court but the Supreme Court
would simply humiliate the Texaco the
justices it didn't even go as far as
discussing whether Texaco should pay
they straight up said that Texaco didn't
not even have the right to appeal this
decision and that their claims lacked
Merit and with that Texaco had no choice
but to pay and given that they couldn't
pay they had no choice but to file for
bankruptcy on April 12 1987. now that
Texaco had been completely driven to the
ground Pennzoil would finally ease up
they would agree to a much lower but
still a devastating amount of 3 billion
dollars Texaco would eventually emerge
from bankruptcy but it was never really
the same they would face a slow decline
throughout the 90s before being bought
out by Chevron for 35 billion dollars in
2000 and over the next decade Chevron
would slowly convert Texaco gas stations
into Chevron gas stations or completely
shut them down despite this there's
still 1 297 technical gas stations
across the U.S today which just goes to
show how big Texaco really was but while
you might be able to spotted Texaco on
occasion the brand is effectively dead
at all because of a hostile takeover
in the end Texaco messed with something
that they had it no business messing
with Getty was a declining brand that
was filled with the drama backstabbing
and ego but ironically everyone on the
Getty side of things came out really
well the Tactical acquisition made
Gordon the richest person in the world
and he's still a multi-billionaire to
this day the board was able to
successfully defend the interests of
shareholders and the museum was able to
safely exit all the drama so somehow
Texaco had solved all of their problems
but they brought on a fatal problem for
themselves if their hostile plan had
worked out they may very well still be
up there on the Fortune 500 list along
with Exxon but their greedy came along
with an 11 billion dollar price tag and
it quickly became a shadow of the past
and that's what happened to Texaco do
you think Texaco deserved what they got
for overstepping Pennzoil comment that
down below also drop a like if you would
like to see more videos about corporate
drama and of course consider checking
out our Discord Community to suggest
future video ideas and it consider
subscribing to see more questions
logically answered but until then I'm
Hari and I'll say guys on the next one
foreign